guten das was admitted to icu with
kovid19 at the start of april 2020. i
was told like yeah okay we'll try to
take you down for a day when i woke up
it was fifth of me
he doesn't remember much of his five
weeks on life support except the
nightmares and struggling to breathe
it's almost like you know if somebody
puts you in
water under water and say like okay you
stop like you can't breathe anymore it's
that kind of feeling really like you
know you just desperate for oxygen
it was inflammation in ghutam's lungs
his immune response to kovid that nearly
killed him the same for the majority of
patients critically ill with the virus
but their ordeal wasn't entirely in vain
he along with thousands of other covid
icu patients allowed researchers here at
the university of edinburgh to sample
their genetic code those genetic
differences that we found in people like
guten
pointed towards potential drug
treatments
they've now established a new hub at the
university to turn those genetic clues
from the pandemic into new drugs to
fight inflammation
not just for treating covid
because the way the treatment work is to
prevent your own immune system from
destroying your lungs and i think
there's there's every reason to expect
that they will also have some use in
other conditions outside of covid but to
make experimental drugs that work they
want to see them in action in real
patients so down the corridor they're
pioneering a technique to do that using
donated human lungs we're trying to do
is to do this experimental medicine
understand if drugs are working in those
furthest most important regions of the
human lung and that hasn't been done
they're using a specially engineered
fibre optic microscope fitted with a
cannula to get the drugs to where they
want them
the tom has got a bronchoscope sitting
here and that goes down the main airways
so he's now walking down the left main
airway as we walk deeper into the lung
you can see it starts splitting off the
smaller branching airways
once the probe is further down where
oxygen passes into the blood itself they
can administer their drug this one
designed to glow when it's at its
destination
what you start to see then these cells
start to light up this is the target now
by the end of the year they hope to be
testing the first drug that they've
engineered here based on that genetic
information they learned from the most
seriously ill patients during the
pandemic but the next step is to use a
miniaturized version of this robot
to deliver those drugs into people's
lungs in a much more precise and
repeatable way
allowing them to spot the most
successful drugs much more quickly
the robotics will be crucial so within
the human lung which is the size of a
tennis court if you lay out flat it's a
large playing field
we want to be able to go back to
precisely the regions we delivered and
aspirated we can't do that with a human
hand if they succeed the aim is to use
their robot to screen tiny doses of
several experimental drugs at the same
time in real patients with severe lung
inflammation
it could help reduce the time to develop
new gene-based drugs from decades to a
few years
not much good came out of the pandemic
but without it we may have waited a long
time for new ideas like this
tom clark sky news edinburgh